Natick Enya and the capital Nairobi
where seven school children have died
after their school building collapse at
least 64 others are in hospital and
family members have been gathering
outside the school there as rescue
workers search for children who are
thought to be trapped in the rubble we
can talk to our correspondent Catherine
soy who's there at the site and
Catherine a dreadful scenario then a
school building collapsing and
presumably not knowing how many children
still may be in that rubble well the
rescue mission is over now so we know
that what has been confirmed as of now
is that seven children have died but as
you mentioned there was a lot of people
here earlier people who live around this
area parents of some of the children who
go to this call and right now nearly
everyone has left we also had from the
Education Minister was here earlier he
said that the government has started
investigations into what exactly
happened so these islands that montine
happened right there it's very difficult
to tell now everything has been cleared
all these books you're seeing strewn
around were left by students as they
were running we've seen many children
who survived the tragedy coming here and
collecting some of the books that are
more intact they're taking them to one
of the classrooms they'll be sorted out
later and perhaps even reused that this
other corner is the debris from that
collapsed building it was a two-story
structure that was constructed using
metal sheets in some wood and there was
a maken creats love that had separated
two stories and people we've talked to
and I've seen as well and these people
who talked to also saying that this
concrete slab was very thinly very
poorly very poorly reinforced so this is
what the minister was talking about as
well they want to investigate how safe
exactly was that building but a very
tragic situation as you mentioned we saw
some parents here alia it's just they
was just unimaginable and I understand
it was a private school Katherine what
kind of neighborhood what kind of kids
would have been going to this school it
was a community school it was a private
school it was registered by the
government but in Kenya in such areas
this is a relatively poor neighborhood
so children were coming to this school
at children who perhaps cannot go to
more expensive more expensive private
schools but then we also have a public
schools but we are also being told that
the nearest public school from here is
about two kilometers away so a lot of
parents choose to bring their children
to relatively low cost schools like this
one there's another one that is
neighbouring here as well and it's the
schools that are sometimes very badly
constructed we've been talking to people
who say that some of these owners of
these schools do not get proper
approvals to build them they're metal
they're made of iron sheets but then
also concrete that is very poorly
reinforced like I mentioned about this
school so those are the kinds of
children that coming in this is what is
tragic because their parents are parents
that cannot afford even perhaps to take
the children to hospitals now the
government has said that it's going to
cater for all the hospital bills of the
children who are in hospital and the
funeral bills of those who have died but
then again investigations going on on to
what exactly could have happened what
exactly could have caused this building
to collapse Katherine so I live in
Nairobi thank you